what's up y'all it's your girl flly and
right now you can catch me on the
bootleg Kev
podcast boot Lake C podcast special
guest here represent Alabama what's up
Flo Millie 251 to be exact I actually
well I can't say this so never mind but
somebody who looks like me might be on
the radio in Alabama soon oh Lord
somewhere what what radio I know listen
I have no idea actually because it would
I am not at Liberty to currently say oh
okay okay so you the maybe one day there
might be somebody shortly who's similar
to me on the radio in Alabama
interesting yeah Mobile Alabama it's
interesting because I've driven through
mhm cuz I used to live in Tampa and so
I've driven like from Tampa to Arizona
twice uhuh and back which is a terrible
drive it's like 36 hours it's wild but
you go up through like the Panhandle
yeah and then there's mobile which is
like at the bottom it's at the bottom
yeah like I drove over a bridge y I
think I got Little Caesars there yeah
honestly the food in Mobile is the best
like is it the best yes I I will I'm
telling you that's the best like what
though like what is there the best of
there everything like when you if you
want to go get some breakfast food you
going to get the best breakfast there
I'm not even exaggerating like that's
how good it is just food period I know
we got like a lot of seafood and [__]
but I'm not like a big Seafood person
but the seafood that they do got is
really good do they got alligator
nuggets I'm sure they do Gator nuggets
are fire yeah they got everything y'all
got Gators in Mobile we do but it's not
like as bad as Florida like you ain't
going to see the [__] out on
the street they're outside I
remember oh yeah you can just pull this
florid yeah um living in Florida like
alligators are like a you know like
they're kind of like raccoons or like
you know like possums they're just there
and they might eat your Pomeranian if
you leave it outside to that's a crazy
ass little animal to have walking around
with a Pomeranian or an alligator an
alligator I have a pomeranian that's me
too for real his name's Labowski mine is
named Sosa wow what color is your
Pomeranian she's like grayish blackish
mine has a brown head and a white body
and he's like my child he's a guy and
he's like my thing oh I came home
yesterday he got excited and peed
everywhere oh wow oh he came he didn't
see me for like a week you know so he
starts dancing and crying and then I got
to pick them up and they pisses on me
yeah because I be hearing like dogs dog
years are different from human years
like a week to them is probably like a
year true because they're they're like
one year seven years mhm so they're like
oh my God my owner what and they don't
know where you're going to come back
they don't got phones they have no idea
they might think you'll be gone forever
yeah they might have already came to the
conclusion like like dad's gone and he's
never coming back and then it's like and
then he sees you and then it's like it's
over I love it is that you only have one
dog yeah just one but I'm not even going
to like act like I be taking care of her
cuz I gave her to my mom so mom takes
care of the dog yeah what okay okay yeah
my mom well actually my mom got tired of
her and gave her to my aunt so now my so
your dog just getting passed around like
leftovers yeah but she's like she don't
don't feel bad for her she's really bad
like she's smart too like she know what
she be doing like she be hiding stuff
under the table one time she got mad I
left her at home chewed up all my Louis
Vuitton sneakers that's when I was like
all right you got to go like you she's a
che yeah especially when she was
teething like I got her when she was
like a baby so yeah and then I started
to like become famous I couldn't it was
hard for me to like take care of her so
I just gave her to my mom and then my
mom gave her to my well shout out to
your auntie yeah free dog a is it a
famous dog does it got an Instagram no
um actually she almost did get famous
but like I don't know it was why did she
almost get how does a dog almost get
famous you have to walk me through this
it's kind of disturbing okay but she I
recorded her like humping this bear on
the floor and like it got like some
views on it but I was like okay I'm
going to take this down cuz she's
[__] shout out to the humping dogs
out there yeah my my Pomeranian will
hump my friend Bulldog wait the
Pomeranian yes to like get it like my
Pomeranian hates my Frenchie so much
that when the Frenchie when the Frenchie
decides like like it's having fun
actively my my Pomeranian hates when my
other dog is happy sorry so he'll start
biting it and like trying to hump it to
get it to like go away and like it's the
weirdest [__] ever that is weird it's
like a reality show with two dogs at all
times yeah it's crazy dogs I don't know
where they get that from yo Alabama has
had like a pretty sick wave the last I
mean shout rip to Doby obviously was
from Montgomery but oh yeah um rest in
peace it's been a very uh like fruitful
like last six or seven years for y'all
yeah yourself blue RI like it's booming
yeah it's so crazy like I remember
watching shout out my guy om yes it's so
crazy you know all of them that's crazy
that's my dog yeah like I I Remember
When Blue was one of the first ones and
people act like Blue's like a new artist
I'm like blue had like gold plaques like
7 years ago like he was one of the first
ones from our city to like blow and I
remember I think I was
like probably just starting high school
and I was tapped into like everything
music cuz that's what I wanted to do I
was like yep he just he went crazy I'm
going to be the first girl like I just
made up in my mind like I don't know how
I'm going to do it but I need to be like
the first one first girl from the city
to like go crazy and and you
accomplished it yeah um you just
announced your new album which can we
say it's like a the third in the trilogy
with the titles yeah lining up so my
last walk us through the first two and
then the third one you just announced so
the first one was ho why is you here ho
why is you here yes and that was a that
really wasn't like an album it was like
a mix tape but still very memorable yeah
and the second one was my first album
It's called you still here ho so that's
like a you know sequel or whatever and
then this one is fine hoste which is
like my most recent body of work so yeah
so for you uh cuz I feel like people
don't do that like you know the little
Wayne used to have the Carter 1 2 3 4
five I mean he probably should stop at
this point cuz Carter 5 was and but
nonetheless a lot of artists they'll
have like sequels to albums and like for
you was it important to kind of keep
some sort of like correlation with the
titles um no it honestly this wasn't
like planned like I know it probably
seemed like it was but it was like the
first one was definitely like all right
this is is what I want my album name I
mean my mixtape name to be and when I
was creating the next album I just
thought of like oh we should make it
like a and then this one I was not going
to do it but then like I like to kind of
listen to my fans and most of them were
like on Twitter talking about like how
they would love if it was a Trilogy so I
was like okay I'mma just give them what
they want and then you know cuz I'd
rather do it now than later but yeah I
feel like it was just kind of like on
the fly like not really like planned
from the beginning but yeah just me
being an artist going through different
like Styles and learning about myself
more and more fire who's on the newest
project can you say it um I could but I
really don't be wanting to can give us
like one
um let's see who I could give y'all just
one let us have it well okay I can tell
y'all my Leo is going to be on the
project okay we got Mona Leo we
got I don't want to tell them I be
feeling okay you don't have to one you
gave me one okay yeah that's a good one
that's dope hey you have um one of my
favorite interviews I've done in the
last like year was Saucy Santana for
real who is like hilarious yeah he's
funny him and I had like a [__] like
a real I was like bro we could kick it
like you know what I'm
saying is cool as hell I was going to
say like obviously you guys have worked
together but you know in this rap game
being somebody who's you know young up
and coming and like scorching hot on
fire I'm sure you have people who are
like acquaintances in hip-hop who you
know hey yeah we'll work and then maybe
you work or you don't work yeah have you
gotten any actual like real friends out
of the rap game yet that was one of them
Mona Leo for sure like she was probably
one of the first not one of the first
but one where I'm like damn like I can
actually pull up on the studio pull up
at the studio and
feel comfortable you know like most
stuff I do is like really like oh their
team send me some or I send them it's
not it's like some email [__] back and
forth or or other people trying to bring
us together I like when it's like
natural and like I actually be like damn
like I could kick it with you like I
could cuz you know we all living the
same not the same life but we're not
we're all in the same field so you know
it's only so many people and like so
many only so many people that can relate
to like the same [__] you got to deal
with right exactly like y'all don't
understand I got to deal with management
I got to deal with I'm about to go on
tour I got to turn an album
in all of that for you uh going on tour
has got to be like uh you
know I always hear that there's like ups
and downs of tour like M are you guys
doing the bus thing yeah I so tell me if
this is true or not but I've heard that
you're not supposed to [__] on the bus
is this true yes oh my gosh and somebody
[__] on the bus last year it was
crazy I was like like what the [__] we
all knew who it was but yeah it was him
no I ain't going to put him out like
that I ain't going to put him out like
that but you know who you is yeah like I
always hear like there's like one rule
do not [__] on the bus and the crazy
thing is the driver told us don't [__]
on the bus and somebody just had to be
that person but so that's one thing
that's one I hear that like socks and
draws are very important on tour like
you can never have more like at least I
heard you got to have like EXT like
brand new socks and drawers like tons of
because doing laundry is a pain in the
ass oh yeah I do that anyway though tour
or not like just in life yeah I just be
like you don't you don't wash like you
just throw away and re and Reby honestly
I be buying too much [__] I ain't going
to lie like I'll be in the store that's
why I really don't like going to the
store cuz I'll just see some [__] and be
like oh I want this I want this like and
I don't even be needing it do you get
rid of like like do you give your stuff
away yeah like recently this year was
the first time time I did that in like
years I got all my [__] out of Atlanta
cuz I had a place there and like I just
gave it to my mom and told her to like
give it away mom give this sh it was
like a bunch of shoes like big ass boxes
of shoes and clothes and you know what
else was in the Box what your Pomeranian
that you to your mom yeah you're like
here give all this [__] away here's the
dog no but I love SOA though she just
she's very hyper like I thought she was
going to grow out of that but like she
be shaking like jumping going crazy I'm
glad she still remembers me though cuz
I'd be thinking like damn I wonder if
she going to remember me like like you
pulled up recently and she got excited
yeah that's tight yeah she didn't forget
I always wonder like cuz you know
there's rappers who will like get rid of
Air Force Ones after one wear oh yeah
and I'll be
like one wear is crazy maybe two where
do the shoes
go like I don't know they need to have a
whole facility for that [__] yeah like
Benny The Butcher wore a pair of shoes
on stage and he was just going to leave
them in the in the Green Room
and I was like I know a lot of people
who do that I ain't going to lie hey I
picked them up I looked at the size my
son will fit these took them [__]
home I said here's here's some Benny The
Butcher Air Force Ones for you kid right
brand new one
wear that's funny that's 90 bucks oh no
they're like a buck 10 now for pair they
used to be 90 Jesus inflation is crazy
has inflation affected you at all um I
mean I'm still blessed I can't say
like it's affected me but I've
definitely noticed the changes for sure
like even in stores like [__] that was
like a certain price yeah like back when
I was like like even 5 years ago even
like two years ago two years ago this
shit's great like gas I mean you drive
around La you see the gas prices are
ridiculous I stay at the gas station but
like that's not a good place to stay at
it's really not the way she said that
she's like yo I stay at the gas station
I'm out here looking for Florida man you
know what I'm saying my car drinks up
gas all oh you have a G wagon mhm are
you based out here or Cali or I tell
nobody I well listen if you anybody who
has to be in California any more than
they need to be the gas here is $7 a
gallon it's [__] terrible that's
crazy it is horrible shout out to the G
wagons yeah you know what's great about
a G wagon is when you bought the G wagon
did you ride it off what you mean r it's
over 6,000 lb so if you have a LLC or
you have like a S Corporation you could
write off that entirely I did okay she
did it I did ta P volume one with FL
Millie right now yeah N G wagons eat a
lot of gas shout out to the G wagon yeah
so I'll be trying not to like but you
right though that's not a safe place to
be like you shouldn't stay at the gas
station you I would send some if I'm you
I got the gas goer i' be like hey I need
y' to go fill my [__] up real quick yeah
I don't trust nobody in my [__] that's
another thing I'm very like if you [__]
up my [__] like I'm going be mad yeah I
feel you I I rather [__] it up myself
was a G wagon like coming up like one of
your dream cars honestly no it was like
really like McLaren's Corvettes and a
McLaren yeah you got some you know do
you know uh you know white clef right oh
yeah he was the first rapper with a
McLaren when I was a kid he was in that
uh magazine uh it was like King Magazine
but they did a car version of it yeah
but anyway it was like a $1.5 million
car he had I never even heard of McLaren
before White had one yeah them them [__]
is hard as [__] like I ain't gonna lie
it's an impractical car though what that
mean it's just like what are you
supposed to do with it like no one can
come with you one person can come that's
why okay I ain't going to lie cuz that's
the one thing I don't like about sports
cars it's like two doors like if you go
get groceries like I can't really get
groceries in this car I can buy like a
little something you know what I'm
saying like yeah but you can't really
enjoy [__] but and it sit so low like
and like yeah if you park it you might
hit the [__] little little divider in
the parking yeah it's too many it's too
many cons I ain't going to lie I feel
like once you have a big truck like
yours M it's like yo I could run over
[__] I could pull up as far as I want in
a parking spot not worry about scraping
my [__] facts but the only thing I have
to worry about now is
like parking garages my car too high
yeah that and not seeing people bro cuz
I I ain't going to tell y'all that no
don't tell us that you hit somebody no I
ain't hit no she's like I didn't see
somebody and
I mean [__] rip no I Ain hit nobody I a
hit nobody but ID be like damn like I
didn't even see that but it's just like
I'm sitting up higher now so it's kind
hard to see was I was in Mexico in my
truck and I didn't realize I was in
Tijana um and I pulled into the hotel
garage without even thinking I just
bought a new truck yeah and uh I wasn't
even like in my head like thinking about
you know cleanance [__] up the whole
top of my roof for real oh my god oh I
know you was pissed week in damn the
first week yeah what is that cuz I mean
that's what I get for driving a car to
Tijana wait Tiana is another it's in
Mexico so if you go to San Diego uhuh
which you should go cuz it's great and
then you cross the border right there
and there's Tana which is the best food
in the
world okay they have uh the best seafood
ever really and the best Mexican food
period do they got fried shrimp though
yeah oh yeah there's a place called lion
fish I feel like I heard of that before
no there's a lion fish in San Diego
that's not related to the lion fish in
Tijana oh okay the lion fish 2 hours
from here you could be eating a lion
fish just hop in the G wagon hours yeah
there's no traffic it's not bad if there
is traffic it' be like four California
traffic is [__] terrible the farthest
I went to a restaurant to like eat was
like an hour that's I mean look there's
certain things I'll drive for and food
is one of them food I love food like
what's your like go-to Cuisine if you
had to like eat anything for the rest of
your life what are you eating damn
that's hard cuz I I'm the type of eater
where like I will eat a certain meal and
then I'll just eat it for like two weeks
and then I'll get tired of it then I'll
find some else to like binge it so what
you on right now right now what am I let
get that mic closer to you too there we
go I'm on like what am I on right
now honestly I've been eating tacos a
lot lately tacos for sure but like good
tacos just all taco trucks
nah I had to stay with I had a bad
experience with a taco truck but like
just different like Mexican restaurants
and stuff Mexican food is the best food
yeah it's so good I love Jamaican food
too Jamaican food's amazing oh my gosh
I've been sleeping cuz but it also like
I feel like you got to have the right
Jamaican food cuz if you have Jamaican
food in certain like when I lived places
listen when I had when I lived in
Florida the I was put on the Jamaican
food oh my God that's where all the
Haitians at that's where all like
everybody at like I wonder Caribbean I
was going to say the Mexican food in
Mobile Alabama has to be terrible you
think so it got to
be I Ain going to hold you like I ain't
never really been to a Mexican mobile
cuz they ain't
there you right they really not though
but like honestly I wonder what is
predominantly there though like probably
um like seafood because the ocean's not
too far yeah the water but one time we
had went to through this like crazy
experience with like the old Spiel
Waffle House is there Waffle House is on
every [__] Corner not in La bro and
mobile I swear to you it's like 20
waffle houses within 5 minutes oh I know
I lived in the South people don't
realize like what's the other place
Cracker Barrel and Waffle House is
[__] everywhere oh and uh what's the
other one what's the golden Corell
golden Corell what a Great Buffet you
could go to the Golden Corral and you
could get up in that [__] and get they
got they got all the steaks like you
need a steak have 10 of
them but the only thing it's not great
food though you'll be [__] your
pants you yo what the you leave the
buffet and you'll be like
damn I think I did too much he hey let
me tell you something you go to a Golden
Corral that's real people watching
especially if you go in the South
they're not going to play they going to
be like but I would not trust it anyway
cuz you already everybody breathing over
the food everything just out in the open
like that's just to me that's nasty if
anybody ever like if you're in the south
you know the two places the people watch
is Walmart at like 11:00
p.m. and the Golden Corral at any time
of
day wait why people people watch it
Walmart je if you ever I mean you've
never been drunk in the middle of the
night and be like let's go to Walmart yo
you know what you got a point I a't been
to Walmart so [__] long Walmart and I
bet you Walmart and Alabama's [__]
turned up oh my God it's so turn we have
a ghetto Walmart it's called ghetto
Walmart I think they're all ghetto
Walmarts but but then there is the
ghetto Walmart in every city and the the
ghetto Walmart in every city that's you
don't want to be at the one they got the
security guards oh man getto Walmart's
lit you go in there you [__] jump in
one of those handicapped [__]
scooters and just ride around
High why that me I used to stay getting
in trouble for that you getting that
scooter and ride around it was that and
going on the bike aisle and riding
around and ride the bikes and then
dribbling the basketballs they have the
big basket of of balls and then you're
just dribbling doing crossovers in the
[__] frozen food aisle hell yeah
going into the [__] what's the other
a called where it's like the electronics
and [__] the speakers and [__] yeah let
me just turn on all the Bluetooth
speakers play the PlayStation that's on
display hell yeah yeah shout out to
Walmart man American treasure like a fun
place when you think about it that's
what I'm saying if you are like and
where I'm from if you got really [__]
like if you didn't have a lot of money
you might go hang out at the Walmart at
midnight with your homies when you're
high if you want to see some [__] happen
like let's just go to Walmart and see
what happens you know what I'm saying
saying we'll get kicked out you know
we'll come back tomorrow you know they
have McDonald's at some of them n for
real that was the best ones the ones
with McDonalds you yies yes yep shout
out to the pretzels man what's your
favorite fast food um probably like
Wendy's Wendy's I love they Baconator
fries yeah the bacon chicken tenders I
mean not chicken tenders the chicken
nuggets the spicy nuggets I don't do the
spicy I do the regulars regulars but
they got to make them extra crispy they
got the for four there yeah I don't eat
burgers though you off the red meat or N
I just never been like a burger type of
girl what yeah I know I'm real like do
you like
sandwiches not really that's wild I
wasn't my mom like never forced me to
like you know how some people be like
you better eat that [__] food like my
mom was not like that even at family
events she' be like no I'm going to make
her plate like she let me hey you got to
try um have you had any and out hated it
oh wow I never ate that food though I
just didn't like I had one did you taste
the burger at Inn out no oh then you
can't even say you hated it if it's
stink I hate it it don't it's it's it's
anything that I don't don't smell good
do you like red
meat I kind of do like I'll eat some
like spaghetti meatballs do you like the
swine what's that like Pig pork bacon
pork CH I'll eat bacon yeah yeah of
course you I mean you like bacon Ator
fries what are you talking about the
swine is divine is what I like to say
if people like I just had Maya the Don
on who's on tour with you shout outs to
her she was like I don't eat swine I'm
like so you eat turkey bacon like why
would you want to eat turkey bacon
that's not good wait we not going to do
that to turkey bacon cuz I was actually
the turkey bacon girl turkey bacon it's
terrible wait not in high school in
elementary school I'm tripping my mom
used to cook turkey bacon every day and
I would like I would be like Mom like I
want like 15 pieces and she and I would
take it to the B stop in a napkin and
then everybody would be eating like I'm
surprised the kids weren't like yo
where's the real bacon no they I don't
even think they question whether it was
like real bacon or turkey bacon but even
my bus driver was eating it hey when you
grow up in Alabama are you automatically
a college football fan no bro like I
don't even know [__] about football I'm
not even going to Li so you're not like
rooll tide or Auburn or I'm going
automatically be Road tide cuz I'm from
Alabama so I just always been around it
where like they just take that [__] so
serious they take it so serious it's
like some real gang [__] like in LA we
got Crips and bloods in like the South
it's like that's the and I thought it
was everywhere I'm like damn like that's
just down there nobody gives a [__]
about college football in La we have
like Caleb Williams in USC here no one
cares yo we got to stop the interview to
tell you about our folks at my bookie
that's right man it is betting season
right now we got football we got
basketball NBA is underway that boy
wanana is looking crazy put all your
money on him to win Rookie of the Year
all right do at my bookie right now go
to my bookie all right when you sign up
at my bookie use the promo code bootle
use that promo code right now and you're
going to get a no
strings cash bonus that's right put your
deposit in withdraw the free cash up to
$200 right away I mean even if you don't
want to bet create an account get an
extra $200 take it out keep it moving
all right but look right now football
season is getting into the thick of it
all right I feel like the playoff
picture is going to start to really kind
of become a lot more clear soon all
right yo shout out to the Bengals
Bengals is finally getting it together
my Cardinals look like absolute dog [__]
which is what I love nonetheless you can
bet every single weekend on my bookie
this is what's upe about my bookie you
could do your daily odds boosts your
same game parlays and the crazy huge
prize pool contest use that promo code
right now on your first deposit so when
you sign up with a new account your very
first deposit use the promo code bootleg
this is important because you're going
to get up to $200 in cash when you use
that promo code bootleg claim your cash
bonus right now no strings attached
deposit withdraw quick there's so much
going on man try the my bookie money bag
to grab a potential Super Bro front
runner at Long Shot odds plus 38,000 on
the Eagles and Chiefs man is crazy you
can bet anything anytime anywhere they
got the full service casino going down
slots roulette whatever it is if you're
into it you can gamble it you can bet it
my bookie sign up with that promo code
bootleg right now
also got to give a big shout out to the
homies at my well I already said my
bookie [__] new commercial shout out to
the homies over at blueo man that's
right blue everybody always ask me does
blue Chu work well you don't take my
word for it try it for free for a month
by using that promo code bootleg right
now blueo has the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Calis uh it's
all wrapped up into a blue chewable form
delivered right to your doorstep and
discret packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free a month supply for free go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg
right now thank me later let's get back
to the interview yeah in the
South like there's like real drunk
redneck like Royal Rumbles and parking
lots even in school like they would
beted on this [__] like everybody beding
even adults like it's like a real thing
like um for you where like I always
wonder when you like you said that when
you were growing up you wanted to kind
of be the first person to pop from your
town M I always wonder like cuz I'm from
a I'm from a city yeah first gr but I'm
from a City Phoenix Arizona no we have
nobody popping God bless us but I always
wonder like when you're coming from a
place that doesn't necessarily have like
the musical like right the music like
like yeah or even just like the Legacy
right like Alabama's like Legacy being
created right now do you feel like the
the burden of like carrying your your
region on your shoulders I feel nothing
like that's the crazy part I never
thought about it like that but I don't
feel like I think it's very powerful
that like it's starting with us but I
don't know why I just don't feel no
maybe because it never happened before
right so it's just something new and I
just like I just feel like okay I'm just
keep getting better regardless of what
where I could have been from LA or New
York like I still was going to have like
big big goals so that's dope yeah where
your first plaque you ever got is it at
your mom's house or is it at your house
where's it at it's one is at my mom's
house I think she took one of them but I
have like two at my house I about say I
think you could probably order more for
Mom yeah you just got to be like I need
two one for mom cuz she took my my
[__] biting ass dog she deserves a
plaque every time we plaque yeah for
sure I got definitely got to get her one
I don't even know how that works like we
got to order that yeah you order it I
just used to get them like sent to me
but okay what was that like though
getting like your first
plaque I was really
just happy was that for conceited it was
for no no it was definitely in the party
no what did I get my first plug for it
in the party yeah and then the next one
was conceited no the next one was beef
and then cassed and then it got Platinum
after that something light yeah has that
has the laat record gone gold yet that
record is [__] huge it's gold oh yeah
know that shit's a big record yeah that
[__] was lit yeah I remember when they
sent me that feature and I I made that
[__] in Atlanta and I just I mean I knew
it was like going to blow up but I was
like damn like I'm surprised nobody ever
tried sampling that record you say
nobody what I'm surprised like that was
the first time someone tried to sample
the genuine Pony [__] oh really it was I
mean I don't ever remember anybody
sampling that [__] I and and and he
killed it it's crazy how like small like
hip hop has not been around that long
like it's crazy like to think about like
it feels like because we was born into
the [__] like it's been happening but no
it's like 50 years yeah quite literally
um who are your goats like who were you
growing up like listening to taking
notes from like
um who was I growing up up taking notes
from really all the women in Hip Hop all
the women R&B like I it was not really
one
specific like genre that I stuck to only
thing I didn't really like listen to was
like country music stuff like that but
everything else I a have no choice like
my mom grew up on Neil Soul Erica Badu
TI Jill Scott all that when I was with
my grandparents it was I think they call
it the eisy brothers e Brothers is the
thing yeah Between the Sheets you know
yeah and then of course Mary Mary like
all the gospel Duos yo did you ever
listen to um Kirk Franklin yep my
grandma we all listen to that that there
was like a real like gospel wave in the
90s yeah that like crossed over like
Mary Mary obviously all that there was
this dude who was always on channel 21
cuz I grew up my best friend his
family's like super religious so I used
to go to like I was the only white dude
in a black church as like a kid oh for
real I know you you you got that soul in
you I was always very like I just felt
like scared why was you scared cuz like
everybody was singing and [__] and I'm
not religious at all my parents didn't
raise me that way so I would just be
every Sunday with my best friend at his
[__] parents house and all these old
like ladies would like put their arms
around me and they'd be singing yeah and
I'd be underdressed like a [__]
in there cuz everybody got crazy ill
clothes on and I'm just in there like in
some shirt and like pants and like I'm
just like I don't know any of these
songs yeah well it's okay like you can
learn them quick but there was a do you
ever hear a guy named Carmen who was
like a singer Carmen he was like he was
like the Jay-Z of gospel music for a
while and then it was like him and Kirk
Franklin but he made different types of
music it wasn't like I think was he like
dark skin I don't I think I don't know I
know it's another one but yeah like I
don't know why when I was younger I used
to think Kurt Franklin and Pla was like
the same the same person yeah yeah I
seen how he living the double life but I
was really young when I honestly it'd be
like much cooler if that was happening
that would be so hard can you imagine if
like he's like I'm going to go record
bus it baby real quick and then I'm
going to go record Stomp and then yeah
we got a double booking cuz uh at 9:00
a.m. I got to go to church and then I
got to go to the strip club at 12 and do
that [__] and you know St Pete or
something yeah shout out to PES man PES
is one of them ones has there anybody um
cuz I always like you know when you grow
up and there's people that you look up
to or that you're a fan of I go through
this [__] all the time when I like meet
somebody um and I'm like I've been in
situations where I'm like I've hung out
with like all five members of Bone Thugs
in harmony at the same time and I'm like
man if you would have told me when I was
a little kid I'd be hanging out with
Bone Thugs That's so crazy have you had
one of those moments recently um damn I
have those moments all the time like
when I run into people and they're like
yo you're killing it I love what you're
doing yeah I'll be like what like I I
just get flashbacks of when I was
watching them yeah but I've had that
moment my mom has had that moment like
what was the moment your mom had um okay
so when I was like really young she used
to play MC light all the time in the car
and so me and my sister we used to like
rap it and we used to rap it for my mom
and stuff and so like going from that
moment which was like years ago to like
now I was at I think the Rock Nation
brunch or something it was either that
one or some Oscar brunch but she was at
my table cuz they signed everybody
tables and like I had called my mom she
was talking to her and she was like dang
I would have never thought like somebody
she grew up listening to she would like
and then like I always talk to MC like
she like tell your mom say hi so it
always like hits her like that that's
sick shout out to MC light the legend
that's incredible um when is I know you
just put the artwork up but when is the
project dropping um we don't have a date
yet but it's coming very soon so I like
the artwork I like yeah is there uh for
you right now like who would you say is
like your next like if you could shine a
light on an artist that you're a fan of
that's like just on the come up just
starting out somebody who you you know
obviously you took you took my on the
road with you but is there anybody who
you think deserves like some recognition
somebody who you know is killing it oh
it's this one girl um dang I feel bad I
forgot the
name
H I got to get her name cuz I it's this
one girl she's like a rapper I've been
seeing her a lot like on Tik Tok but I
think she's like on the come up right
now okay I I forgot her name but it's
like this light-skinned girl I mean
that's so like so many light people but
yeah I don't know her name but if I had
to name another
person I don't know like a lot of them
are already like lit like doing their
thing yeah like it's hard for me to find
new artists so many dope rappers on Tik
Tok that like if you scroll like you'll
be like oh this mother like I feel like
we be finding new artists to come up
here and rap just off of Tik Tok
sometimes cuz you'll be like oh this
[__] this dude this dude's ill I'll be
I'll be more so like watching artists
who I feel like really got that like cuz
I'm good at that like when I first even
before like I was taking music serious I
could predict when a person was like
going to get famous like even before
they had like a lot of followers I would
see them and it would always be right
and I had nothing in the show for it I'm
like bro I found an artist like be an
anr have a label you would you ever want
to have a label probably one day you can
sign artist yeah but I would probably
wait till I'm like really established
cuz I don't want to play with no no yeah
yeah that's the one thing like you said
that's important cuz a lot of people
just want to have a label cuz they feel
like it's the thing to do when you make
it yeah it's like you're kind of playing
with people's lives low key yeah so so
it's like you don't want to be in that
position like you got to get your [__]
to where you're like I can chill a
little bit cuz it's a human being like
you know and even if they're with you
for two years it's like I don't want to
waste two years of your prime your yeah
for sure if I'm not going to do right by
it so that's dope well look you're on
tour you got uh I think your next tour
dat's in Denver yep I think it is Denver
you smoke uh weed all the time nice yeah
nice so if you got some I got some drugs
for you do you do shrooms no no never do
the shrooms we got to change
that you got to give him a shot oh know
but do them at home okay at the crib
pressure for me just play some music
like some like Erica Badu eradu throw on
like just a cool playlist you giving me
Gemini Vibes what's your son I am um you
know what's funny is I'm not into I'm an
aquarius I almost said I'm on aquini
which is the name it's the name of that
Outcast album right there um but no I am
a uh I was born in January okay I was
born in January too I'm the
27th okay I'm the 20 I mean I'm not the
20 anything I'm the ninth so are you a
Aquarius no I don't know when the cut
but I'm very kind of similar cuz what's
the cut off when's the Aquarius season
start and end I don't know I think it's
like at the end of January but so what
are you then I'm a Capricorn see I don't
know about any of this where it do you
believe in this stuff yeah okay I just
see to me that kind of like like the uh
horoscope thing M like is it accurate
like I
mean we don't have to go down that
rabbit hole but I'm just curious like
you like have you met somebody been like
you're not C like like compatible cuz I
know people who won't date somebody if
they're not if they're in like some
range of like when were you born ah we
ain't going to work yeah are you one of
them it's like yeah I'm one of them oh
wow I mean I don't be doing that like
I'm not going to lie to you I don't be
like oh if you're this like I don't
really so what's what's your like in
incompatible sign according to you know
the horoscope books that people read
probably umbly
probably Aries an Aries I don't know
when is that I think that's like March
so if you're born in March don't even
call no it could be two things though
yeah cuz like it ain't it don't end like
some of them be starting like in the
middle she was born in January and she
and she's Aries Capricorn sorry she's
Capricorn I was born in January and I'm
Aquarius Aquarius so I could Aquarius
yeah
SE mhm so basically Aquarius yeah but I
think you get along with Aries Aquarius
is but Aquarius y'all are like very
like rebellious all right man I also
want to give a shout out to our family
over at King pom baby you already know
man we always stay King pomed up over
here it's the only thing we're smoking
you know what I love about King pom so
many
flavors so natural organic tobacc free
leaves this is how we're smoking at the
bootleg Kev podcast and um like let me
just say this dude like all shapes and
sizes you know what I mean like it's
give you a little variation of the type
of King Pals you can get down with you
know just different shapes different
sizes
natural organic tobacco free a clean
smoke if you will so many the this is
the honey berry which might be my new
favorite I do love the uh the energy
drink one the red rain is fire all right
um but listen if you want to get down
with some of these King Palms trust me
when I say man they are the best way to
smoke um first of all you can go to your
local liquor store 7-Eleven all that
they got King poms all right so go pick
something up or you can go to their
website now if you go to their website
King pom.com go to King pom.com use the
promo code bootle right now and uh you
can say 50% off at King pom.com half off
whatever you want what are we
smoking this is the uh the Orange Swirl
what's dope about King pom is they have
like the flavor the tarpine infused tips
so like let's say you got this one right
you got some of that Orange Swirl you
feel
me you load it up put your wheat in
there or whatever your
tobacco and then in the tip you press
down on that thing and you're getting
hit with all that
flavor all right so go to uh King
pom.com use the promo code bootleg right
now get half off or just go to your
local liquor store go to your local
7-Eleven and run it up with some King
Palms also want to give a shout out to
our family at odd Sox man don't forget
get you some odd Soxs in your life go to
oddsocks official.com right now holiday
season's coming they make great gifts
man we can do so much they got the ET
you mean they got the draws if you a
know odd Soxs making underwear now and
they're more comfortable than all the
other underwear Brands let me be honest
with you all right they got all the
licenses how about Top Ramen underwear
let me just take a peek of these bad
boys
see what we got here the ramen draws
baby what how about some Mountain Dew
Code Red Socks or or you know what how
about this how about we we keep the soda
theme going we got Mountain Dew Baja
Blast oh wait wait wait wait wait we we
we don't want either of those we'll keep
the soda theme going what about some
orange crush socks what if you're fat
like me you like chocolate Hershey's
they got WWE Breaking Bad Godfather good
I mean just all of the damn things Power
Rangers all the crazy licenses go to
oddsock official.com use the promo code
bootleg right now and you will save 20%
off oddsock official.com promo code
bootleg save 20% off your total order
right now let's get back to the
interviews yall are very rebellious
y'all try to like not follow the rules
yall are very different have your own
mind very what's the
word so far your spot on yeah like
aquariuses are the type to invent things
they are very much geniuses is like I'll
take all of these compliments I give you
a I'll give you a whole an analysis of
it like one time I went to New York and
I guessed people sign on the street and
I got it right really mhm and that video
shoots I'll be doing that too and they
be like so shocked um Libras are crazy
people why you say that I just that's
something I I know to be true really
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've had my uh yeah
there certain Libras are psychopaths so
shout out to my uh hopefully you know my
kids a Libra now so hopefully he doesn't
grow up to be some toxic
[__] shout out to the Libras so what
is a Capricorn's you just gave me my
rundown what's your rundown of a
Capricorn okay so like a
Capricorn weird okay every sign has like
an by the way the fact you believe in
all this and haven't done shrooms is
crazy well you got to tap in bro I don't
know I'm not really like a drug person
it's not drugs yeah like weed hey weeds
aren't weeds not drugs right I mean it's
drug is it is but it's it's a drug that
it's very harmless yes and so are
mushrooms they're even more harmless oh
even more harmless they're not addictive
they're therapeutic they're
amazing so Capricorns give me the
rundown Capricorns like okay you know
how like so your sign is like I think
y'all are like the water barrier yeah
some of water yeah mhm so mine is like
the goat so you're the goat yeah I'm a
goat so basically like if you think
about that like we kind of like reach to
the top like we're very like ambitious
people I like that um very much A lot of
people some people would say like we
Workaholics and stuff but I think it's
just because we want to succeed in life
like that's a strong desire do you feel
like you have issues like putting you
time aside so you where you're not
working and you're not focused on your
career like do you ever take time to
just kick
it probably sometimes but most of my
life is dedicated to what I want my
purpose to be like I'm thinking ahead
like I'm not trying to be older and then
like saying oh I wish I would have did
that like I'm just trying to like go
crazy now that way I can rela later yeah
what is your
purpose H I don't know that's
interesting you ask me that cuz I feel
like I know my purpose but I feel like
as I'm growing as a person it evolves it
evolves and changes and grows so I can't
tell you the full purpose but I know
right now I feel like I've learned over
the past year that years that my purpose
was to kind of like give girls
confidence just off like my tour like
having girls talk to me and tell me like
that I dropped this at a time where like
they needed it yeah they was going
through a breakup and I helped them to
with by me being confident I helped them
be confident so I feel like it's like
that like you know how like people they
try to find something to cope with [__]
like music can be that for people so
yeah music is like people's therapy it
gets people through the worst times in
life it's crazy cuz I mean you know this
you're a big fan of music like you could
like hear a song and remember where you
were in life I think that is so powerful
like I would never forget like when
albums dropped where I was like what I
was doing and now people are doing that
to your music and then they're coming
and seeing you and and giving that
experience to you that's dope yeah
that's got to be crazy cuz like I always
see artists like I feel like if I could
touch people that way like I would never
like retire yeah cuz you'd be like man
I'm like here for so many people yeah I
think it's just such a cool thing
because it's like you get to the the
path that I chose I get to like be on
like present everywhere like I get to
even when I'm not in rooms like my work
is there my art is everywhere you know
what I'm saying it's going to be here
forever so that's something that was
like really important for me like
leaving like a legacy yeah people don't
realize the music is never going to go
away you might you know yeah but it's
music will be here forever yeah that's
dope well hey congrats uh the tour is
going crazy I think uh you got what like
16 dates yeah it's like a like almost a
month so yeah so you're going to be
everywhere yep so go see uh is there a
city you're most excited to go to I'm
excited to go to Texas and I'm going to
Texas wait when you in Texas like it's
like the middle of the tour it's the end
oh it's the end oh I was about to say
we're going to be in Texas this weekend
Austin oh W what dates she's be there I
think it's 11 12 13
oh I'm going to go hog hunting in Texas
this weekend with that Mexican OT oh
[__] so y'all going to go like kill pigs
yeah damn I feel bad about it but
anything for
cont well in Texas they're evasive
species oh really and they like ruin
crops and like kill animals really cuz
they're like Hogs like you know like you
know like Pumba from Lion King he's got
those big tusks yeah like those mother
them pigs be [__] FS up so in Texas
they're like a
problem cuz they there's so many of them
so I'm going to be in a helicopter with
that Mexican OT you know who that is
uhuh he's like a the chubby Mexican
rapper and he has a cowboy hat and
glasses and he can rap really really
good oh wow that's crazy so we're going
to be um we're going to be so y going to
be shooting from a plane that's kind of
helicopter a helicopter yeah I'm like I
don't know how this is going to go
that's really you know what I was on a
plane watching this one I think it was
animal channel or some whatever history
that [__] and it was like people like
trying to stalk polar bears and they was
doing that it was in a helicopter like
stocking polar bears yo I was on a plane
yesterday and I was uh I ate uh I was
high on the plane
and we were flying in the middle of the
clouds and I was [__] freaking the
[__] out don't do it again cuz that
happened to me with an edible I opened
the goddamn window and we're in the
[__] clouds bro we were first we were
floating on top of them and then we we
went inside of them and you can't see
[__] and I was like what the [__] yeah
close
that yeah shout out to the uh to the
clouds it was like right when we were
getting into La so we were like kind of
floating right above the clouds yeah and
you I'm like yo work this is crazy the
right there do you remember your first
time getting on an
airplane yes I was in high school yeah I
was super scared cuz I'm like afraid
afraid of heights yeah so yeah I was in
high school I think I was like 16 the
first time I flew and it was uh it was
it was trippy cuz then turbulence
happens yep I love turbulence that's a
wild thing to
love it's a crazy thing to say she's
like you know turbulence I love that
[__] I'm honestly like for real for real
like I'm a daredevil like I've always
been like that girl just doing like SI
line and roller coaster like yeah like
when I was a kid all my little cousins
like they would be the ones scared to
get on like the mega drop I was like
y'all [__] weak like I'm ready to do
all this [__] would you guys go like do
you is there theme parks in Alabama go
to Florida or had no we had this um what
was it called it was like a state fair
oh yeah the state fairs be lit those are
the those rides be shaky as [__] though
cuz then it's like some like inbred dude
running it who just got out of jail so
why that's the the cars they call them
said just got show crazy I didn't even
know those the people who operate rides
at state fairs are sketch as [__] see
I'm I wish I would have known that cuz I
was freely trusting all that [__] like
it was just so like the slingshot thing
that you pay 50 bucks to get on is
insane like it's crazy no one of the
rides that used to really scare the [__]
out of me was the 3,000 ride you
remember that is that the one where
you're like laying back and then you
just bro I was so sick you can't like
lift yourself up not you're going so
fast that you can't lift up that [__] is
too scary have you um done any of the
theme parks here in California yet um I
think I went to Six Flags I took my Six
Flags turned up and kns Universal is
cool but it's more like you know you go
to like hang out with Super Mario at
this point and like Harry Potter's there
yeah no but Six Flags was way more fun
out here than Atlanta cuz it's way
bigger like yeah Six Flags is where it's
at everything else Orlando's where to go
oh yeah Orlando La versions suck
compared to Orlando and I heard that
when I went to Orlando when I was eight
Orlando's turned up Universal Studios is
twice the [__] size facts I don't
think they have a Super Nintendo World
there yet though nah they got they got
the epard um well I ain't been there in
years I'm over here acting like I I
haven't been there since I was a kid but
the last time you haven't done a show or
anything in Florida or nothing I only
been to Disney World no I'm talking
about Disney World oh Disney World yeah
yeah I only been to Disney World one
time in my entire life yeah I've only
gone once but I never went to the Epcot
I only went to like the Magical Kingdom
or whatever it's called did you go on
the incredible Hook Brad yeah this one
that's the first one terrible right see
I like certain [__] like I just did knsb
farm and I was this was like last
weekend I went with my wife's uh well we
all went but me me and her stepdad rode
all the crazy roller coasters and I was
I hated him cuz he dragged me on that
one that just drops it takes you to the
[__] top oh yeah that's the one then
it goes and then it goes like this and
then it say sh shoot so you don't know
where what's going to like you don't
know when you're going to fall and then
it doesn't look as tall as it is when
you're on the floor you're like man that
ain't [__] yeah and then you get up
there and you're like [__] yeah like I
don't know that type of [__] excite me
though but the older I'm getting I don't
know like I don't know
mushrooms mushrooms we got to push
mushrooms on FL Milly everybody yall see
this right here your new album is coming
soon you're on the road go support her
in whatever City uh she is
nearby um and uh hopefully the album
comes out really really soon oh yeah you
won't be disappointed I'm sure it'll be
out in like the next 60
days
is neither confirmed or
disconfirmed and uh yeah well I
appreciate you coming through and
hanging thank you I appreciate you guys
for having me
BL [__] yo we're wrapping up an
interview man of course we want to shout
out to our family at harden baby Harden
Las Vegas celebrating their seventh
birthday this month so happy birthday to
harden uh want to give a shout out to
the whole family over there when you're
in Las Vegas you got to pull up the
Harden tell them that the bootle C
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in s City so you land in Vegas you
about to go gamble with your boys you
get in that cab you say take me to
harden they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
harden go follow him Hardin Las Vegas or
go to the website Hardin vegas.com